definitely did not take too much Liberty
giving people Joyrides in that Porsche
356. so you had it for multiple days
just one the dude picked it up the next
night he blew so much smoke up my ass
like inflated my ego way too much when
he dropped it off why he's like you're a
cart driver right I'm like oh let's go
[Laughter]
am I and then you woke up yeah oh yeah
yeah it was an Italian man be like you
drive so well yeah yeah you're the
greatest car driver in all of Italy wow
you drive like Mario yeah the way you
thread the input
you're not like a toad you're more like
Mario
Bowser has nothing on you
and then I woke up
um no really he was like Dutch okay
um I'm like the [ __ ] are you doing here
in Italy man he's like you're a car
driver that's not Dutch at all he's like
basically you don't have a car yeah
he's like basically you're going to uh
the input to schwarried whatever
whatever I'm like cool cool so I spent
the next morning you know hauling some
people around that was great and then
definitely like a cool part of the week
oh my God not like the coolest but
definitely a cool part
second coolest definitely the thing that
I wasn't immediately awake for
was going to a cart track okay oh I
found one okay it's like it's like one
of the only ones in that like so karting
is popular in Northern Italy and we're
like in the middle in this like middle
South and this is like the only car
track in all of like the middle of Italy
so I'm like gotta do it it's in Sienna
and uh this is like you're on your
honeymoon no uh no so like we took the
family okay okay yeah yeah everyone's
still there so I'm like this will be fun
um we get there so I've been talking to
this dude he works for the FIA which
like oversees that's like the
organization that like rules over
Formula One like Motorsport in Europe he
was like yo I'm gonna put you in touch
with Danilo Rossi this guy's like a
five-time cart Championship like Legend
and I like correspond the dude and he's
like yeah I'll be there just like shoot
me some cash and I'll bring you a
shifter card I'm like no [ __ ] way so
like I was like kind of racing the
family and then he I was putting in a
few sessions with him
and it's really funny
like
yeah
yeah that's a picture of you from the
thing yeah
so they really do have the shells
floating around yeah wow yeah yeah
there's a big dinosaur that drives
around on track too again like a yeah
and a girl yeah okay yeah wow
basically my brother-in-law
that dude's like 260. okay six five big
boy yeah dude he put on a helmet it was
like a he looked like a martian like it
was like a round thing on top of his
head with some sunglasses he was Bowser
for the day we were we were dying dude
and every time we go out there he's like
is there anything that can like handle
my weight I'm like that
so the dude Danilo uh big shout out to
him for putting up with me stranger
cards fast as [ __ ] I'm not very
experienced with them it was funny
watching like he's such a good coach
I like did a few laughs and he just
holds his hand up to stop me I'm like
what's up dude he's like
relax
[Laughter]
he's like
no need to
like mocking the way I'm driving kind of
I'm starting to feel bad I'm like you
know I won't do that anymore sorry he
like coached me through some [ __ ] and
that was cool and then uh wait so you
brought the family there to race
go-karts yeah and it was it fun oh yeah
like it yeah okay my dad drove like a
[ __ ] psycho that's what everyone
learned okay almost broke his [ __ ]
ribs really you're just getting into
tussles with people wow yeah he's in the
family yeah I guess yeah diving on the
inside I was trying to get around him
I'm like dude I didn't know it was him
at first I'm like who the [ __ ] am I oh
Dad
um whoops
it's pretty crazy
uh yeah yeah
I had to get him back
um
I egged Siva on to follow me through a
corner and I just binned him so hard it
was pretty funny I'm like no dude you
got it you got it
it just went spinning I was like see ya
I had to get him back because I was
driving by Alina and she was doing well
and I like threw her a thumbs up and I
spun her out like getting her attention
and she was like I was just so excited
to see you
I saw that I spun her out and I saw
Steve again in front I'm like I gotta
take him out
I gotta take care of my lady here
emotions don't belong on the track babe
yeah
you should know better all right yeah
yeah it's life or death out there every
single time
I was so excited to see you
you should have kept that in yeah
you should wait till after must be why
you lost yeah
um
Italians are super animated the guy who
owned the track was getting so angry
when people would spin out it was
comical he'd be like screaming at they
can't hear him he's like
is it not allowed I mean you're allowed
but he was just like frustrated watching
it I guess
and so yeah he was yelling at everybody
to slow down and yeah whole thing was
great
um it was funny seeing the parents out
there Elena's dad put in some work damn
yeah dude uh he came from like 9th to
third or some [ __ ] it's pretty sick
everyone had a good day out there
we did that and then um
saw some medieval [ __ ] some Churches and
yeah yeah just got some history a lot of
food I can tell you I don't want pasta
again really I'm good man I went to a
pasta making class last night ooh
where at your kitchen doesn't count bro
no Italy Italy
worse yeah even worse so I'm just like
you're telling me all this and I'm
really feeling it because I feel like I
was there last night you know what I'm
saying like I just
just really feel The Vibes same sort of
energy dude it is so funny
how when you go to Europe all the
history that's there which by the way as
much as it's great you know internet is
[ __ ] atrocious in Europe those
buildings are old as [ __ ] there's no
Wi-Fi router that can get through that
okay you know but it just made me laugh
about America and how much weak cosplay
as other [ __ ]
you do you get what I mean yeah you like
you going to Italy yeah yeah to do a
pasta making class and it's led by some
yoga instructor we're gonna learn how to
make pasta yeah it was kind of like I
mean he I think he was Italian but at
the end of it he got very good accent so
you weren't sure
yeah well he also like kind of I wasn't
yeah I wasn't really sure he also like
kind of had a lisp so I wasn't sure what
was the idea no
you started bagging on the list
no but he made us pause at the end like
he taught us how to do it it was really
fun and then he made us a bunch of pasta
at the end yeah it like kind of sucked
it like wasn't good everyone like
everyone in the class was like yo is
there salt
and salting the [ __ ] out of the thing it
was like yeah I was kind of
disappointing but the making the pasta
was fun I don't think Italian like I
think that's just our shitty diet I
think we salt the [ __ ] out of everything
I kind of noticed that there too that I
was adding salt to everything even the
dope ass meals I'd be like
really we get a little added salt to
every single thing yeah it can be a
little in that [ __ ]
it's because they're they're healthier
what was the best meal
honestly
honestly nice truffle salad
not even because whatever was probably
the wedding meal oh yeah we hired a dude
who Ace Chef oh that's great yeah I feel
like wedding food normally sucks yeah
that's what I was afraid of yeah when I
saw like I mean you know how it goes
you're paying this dude a [ __ ]
boatload and I was just biting my tongue
like this food better not suck [ __ ] and
the fact that he was just like yeah just
send it over I'm like it's a lot of
[ __ ] money bro it's cash in the mail
please yeah yeah my PayPal is uh send it
now at paypal.it yeah
that guy
she did a cooking class with the family
and he similar thing just had everyone
make pasta she was amazing I thought it
was gonna be ass because I was looking
at it and when the plates came out by
the way lost all my gains okay yeah yeah
you know yeah Europe it's just you're
not gonna eat yeah ever yeah or I mean
it's the oh yeah for you I guess that's
the issue for me it would be like eat
way too much
yeah
I guess I mean we're doing a lot of
things so I guess that's why we weren't
gonna eat you in theory you can eat a
lot in Europe there's definitely plenty
of places that serve burgers and [ __ ] no
McDonald's it's just if you can get in
and out of the restaurant in under four
hours
that [ __ ] is so crazy uh we ate
somewhere and the reservations were just
7 30 and 9 30. what yeah
that's it huh and like it was really
interesting like we got there at seven
and clearly everyone was there for that
slot everyone filled out
we dipped around 9 30 and there's like a
big crowd and like we just like did a
swap and then that was it wow it's
pretty cool but yeah uh lots of gelato
it was great amazing